I heard the amazing words of enthusiasm
and I really like amazement of his agent
Brian's warstrom who is my dear friend
and Brian started to describe me this
young man in ways that made me my
attention like flip then I'm your agent
that's a good Agent yeah but it wasn't
really a great agent of course I mean
but I was not just agenting he was
really passionate about you
in a way that really creates an image in
my mind that of course was met with even
greater enthusiasm when I met the
gentleman in front of me here now are
they watched us I don't actually mean
many others
why did you happen to bring me along
being nice I am nice
but then I saw Timmy in interstellar I
loved the movie it was great I mean
Chris Nolan
but I knew that Timothy was in it so I
was driven by that desire in the first
place seeing I am love and just admiring
the acting and admiring the story but
also admiring just the quality of it
that fell Beyond me and my experience in
New York at the time and there's just
wonderful performances in it too you
know and it's how I felt when I watched
a bigger Splash when I was in Luke's
apartment in Kramer and we're about to
shoot coming by her name I just thought
oh wow I'm in these safest hands from an
active perspective but also from a
visual perspective and uh I'd like to
you know it still is in my life these
beautiful idyllic settings although I've
been in more of them but it really
wasn't when I was in when we were
getting ready to call me by our name and
stuff I thought it was just
total dream like the breakfast setting
of the table and I was a Cocoa Puffs kid
I am privileged because I I 99 of the
time meet great artists in my work and
so I embraced by their commitment and
their intelligence in understanding
performance and and and and kind of like
investigating human nature so that they
can then translate it into what they do
as a performers so when you meet people
that are as extraordinary as Timmy you
want to keep the conversation because as
deeply we went we'd call me I feel like
we have many more things to do and many
more aspects of portrait of people that
we can do together and it's beautiful
and it's uh fun and it's reassuring you
know like when you're in a family you
can show sides of yourself that are not
the most let's say public
and but you are in the safe hands of
your family and I think that is a great
way of living and that's fantastic to do
um in film because you can really be
open and completely fragile in front of
the people that you love and they love
you so that you can then find things
that are deeper probably I thought
documentary on the making of Fanny and
Alexander by Bergman and he made that
last movie he made was the previous to
the last but he made it with a lot of
his group of actors and people and and
you could see how Berryman was really
open to show what he didn't know more
than what he knew
and I think what do we do is searching
for with what we don't know and then be
kind of confident that we can really
show up that we don't know much but we
can try to find the answer of what we
don't know I think there are multiple
moments uh where I was given that
feeling like we started the interview
with I feel like the second Luca gave me
that opportunity not only to be incoming
their name but without an audition which
Taylor has talked about now with bones
and all that leap of faith when you're
coming up as an actor there's a lot of
rejection that reactor's gone through it
so to get that sort of Bridge to the
promised land without the jumping
through hoops that is so involved in the
process it's almost too good to be true
and then the experience that I had on
Bones and all but also probably by her
name where Luke is priority is the Arc
of the story of the behavior of the
human within it to capture Humanities
the biggest insecurities and
self-doubt self-loathing all the things
that make us truly human and it's just a
dream and it's what makes me so grateful
at the great reception the movie's got
but also how much people have been
showing up to the premieres and stuff
because
so much of what gets consumed in Media
or music or or film there's higher
corporate interests there's Focus
grouped scripts and promotional
materials and this is a really good Nino
film with a loopy wedding a poster and a
little letting you know marketing and uh
I and Taylor are you know watercolors
and that's man I want to do it again and
again with Luca that sounds weird
you don't think I'm a bad person
I mean I felt very strongly that Taylor
was a great companion piece for us and
that she was going to become a partner
of accomplice in the process and then we
all gathered at the house of Peter
Spears of a wonderful producer and we
made the makeup and hair test and coffin
test for like a month and a half two
months before shooting and that was
already a nice moment of breaking the
eyes I think there was something about
Taylor that was about being really like
ready to go and jump into the pond and
really swimming to this into these
Waters of this movie without any uh
other structures in her mind which
sometimes can happen and Timothy is like
that as well there was a great meeting
there it was a great partnership
happening but it was a party that
involved Timothy and Taylor the team
working on the on the visual of the
aspect of the characters there was also
our wonderful DP arseni so we started to
build a nudge of what was going to
become the experience one thing that I
loved very much throughout the process
is how wonderfully Shiva Rose you were
with Taylor and how you really held her
hand throughout the process and yeah I
mean she doesn't need to be held a hand
but at the same time it's like you get
into a place where there is already a
partnership or a communion and you want
to feel included and that was wonderful
but also she was so generous like I will
never forget the intensity of her
vibrations
performing the first few days
we started the movie with we started the
movie working with her and with the
Magnificent Andre Holland which I
completely adore and I salute Andre is
one of the greatest so like and I saw
that and I thought that we were shooting
Marin abandoned being finding herself
alone in the house and the way in which
she really summoned much of her inner
spiritual world to show that on screen
for the camera was amazing you know like
I love actors that they do not resort to
the trickeries of being actors who
performed drama I don't I think that's
now evident in my work I like actors who
are committed to really go and be raw
and naked in front of the camera
metaphorically sometimes and not only I
didn't know I had permission to murder
into me
you want it darker
we kill the flame
it's almost like if we were shooting
we were in a Roman room right now
there's beautiful Roman art on the walls
and it would be to if I were to go into
another project it would be to take in
every living fiber of the room the way
on a company by her name or a bigger
Splash those fibers could induce Envy by
the elevated lifestyle and how
scrumptious Everything feels and
delicious and on Bones and all it can
kind of repel you sometimes the
intensity the condition these characters
are living in but I just remember on
coming by her name the hairdresser
getting sick and somebody having to come
in and and
if I can share it and Luca basically
doing it himself because he was so
specific to the hair that he knew how to
do it himself or in the breakfast scenes
I don't remember this too that you were
arranging the the food exactly she
wanted to be or here on Bones and all
there's a set but Luca was physically
destroying you know he's he's a
Craftsman in that way and not to just do
an ad for Luca but he does interior
design and he's always
he's always sketching on his iPad which
is a nice joke Zendaya and I have on on
set because if we're on our phones or
whatever sometimes we'll assume the Luca
posture and because he can't stop he
literally can stop and uh that's so cool
to be in partnership with that and uh he
these are the like the true creatives to
their bones you know
I went to Budapest to meet the and Timmy
and I was and we were doing ADR for for
Z on on Challengers and we did that on
your background yeah and I went into the
Backlot and I saw a huge tune set I went
there and I touched all there was the
helicopter that was a moment thing which
I could see Mercy have been the
wonderful craft I mean wow you sketch
you etched your name into one of them I
wanted to yeah I said no no don't do
that
you look like the kind that's convinced
himself he's got this under his thumb
already
[Music]
my Lord
I like this word Luke has been using
vibration because the movie's really a
vibration and uh to to the fact that
there was no I don't think there's any
day that felt confirmed because it just
felt like just these expressions of
identity and a story but that day on the
in Nebraska
um
on the eclipse Edge yeah that scene
between Taylor and I
there were these horror elements there's
these cannibalistic elements so to
capture a scene between two humans that
felt about
sharing the innermost parts of you that
make you feel the most insecure and
being seen by someone else being loved
by someone else being held by someone
else having space made for your trauma
that felt like we were onto something
special and then then I must play the
same that they those three days we shot
over three sun sets and one Sunrise
where just incredible and
Sublime and there was a collapse a
collapse of things happening there first
of all
Lee spurting out the truth of himself to
Marin and Marin and Lee
finally releasing one another to one
another then there was Nebraska such an
incredibly beautiful place then there
was the light of Nebraska the sunset and
the sunrises are amazing you know Luke
alluded to it earlier the production
started in sequence with Andre Holland
and Taylor so I visited seven of those
earliest days and just to sing Taylor's
Praises just seeing the kind of work she
was doing with Andre right away I feel
like if anything I felt like oh man I
gotta stop my game up because she was
just bringing it immediately you know so
I felt like our movie's protagonist
Taylor from the beginning it was like it
was on
[Music]